Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on guys?
This is Rob. And, uh,
have you guys seen the previews for future state Superman worlds of work?
It looks amazing, right? It's written by Becky Cloonan.
It basically looks like Superman, like planet Hulk with Superman,
but it looks cool. Like I'm super excited to check it out,
but I just happen to think about that.
So we are covering the origin of clown Hunter,
which is something that a lot of the guys have asked for.
And it's actually very fortuitous. We waited until now,
because I didn't realize DC was going to be releasing a one-shot origin of clown
Hunter, which I would have known had I just looked it up. But, uh, it's cool.
Right? We've got this. Now.
This is the full on origin of his character because in a lot of ways we didn't
really know what all went into his character development.
We simply just knew that he became clown Hunter because his parents were killed
during, or at least at some point by the joker. Right?
So this gives us the full on origin, which I'm excited to cover.
So here's the thing this initially opens up really with Leslie Tomkins and crime
alley right now, Leslie Tomkins holds you guys who don't know,
she's kind of like the night nurse of DC comics, right?
She's been around for a really, really long time,
but she's the one who kind of runs this free clinic down in crime alley in order
to serve those individuals who were underprivileged, right? Whether they're, uh,
vigilantes or sometimes even criminals or people who can't afford to go to like
a hospital, because they don't have health insurance or something like that.
She basically tends to their, uh, to their,
their injuries and their wounds and so on. And so because of that,
she's very much a respected member of the community.
And this really is really kind of reflected when you have this guy who shows
about a nowhere looking to Robert, right?
Like to literally like Rob a woman who runs a free clinic in crime alley right
now, this guy, big Eddie kind of shows up and he's like,
look like this is Leslie Thompkins that you're robbing. So like,
I'm going to break you apart piece by piece. If you don't get outta here,
Neil you'll guy, the Robert ultimately leaves. Right.
But the important thing behind this is that once Leslie gets to her clinic,
she's met by the arrival of clown Hunter, right by by bat,
I think is how you pronounce his name, but the whole point behind this.
And the reason why this matters is because he comes in there really kind of
having his injuries tended to after he, uh, after he left right in the,
the last Batman story arc that we covered, where he almost killed Harley.
And that's kind of what he says, right? She's like, you know, why,
why are you here now? But like why, why come to this place now?
And the reality is he's experiencing an existential crisis.
And the reason for that is we jumped back to three years prior and you've got
him just kind of in his bedroom, playing video games,
his mom kind of gets and says, look, either you could have helped me downstairs,
right. Or you can help me around the house and Earl stances,
like I give you a choice, right?
Either you could clean up your room or you could help your father downstairs,
get ready for the dinner rush. Right. And he's like,
there were only two people in the restaurant yesterday,
what kind of a dinner rush is there really? But you know,
ultimately his mom's just, you know, his mom does what mom's do, you know,
which is like, I will, I brought you into this world now we'll take you out.
So ultimately of course he ends up going downstairs and helping his dad enter
Harley Quinn and Harley Quinn of course shows up with our two hyenas. Now,
given the way she's dressed and so on, you know, this is, you know,
relatively soon to when she ended up leaving joker or at least sometime around
relatively soon, one thing to keep in mind when it comes to comics,
you don't keep, uh, keep track of real-world events. So I have real world time.
And so while it's technically three years ago, uh, this could have been,
you know, 20 years ago or 10 years ago in comic book time. Right.
So it's one of those weird kind of funky things where it's like, eh,
it's just at some point along the line with Harley Quinn. Right. Uh,
but when she shows up here, she's kind of like, so Mr. Mitchell J the joker,
like we literally just got done knocking over a whole bunch of jewelry stores in
the diamond district and we're hungry. So I told him that, you know, I,
I used to have full all the time when I was younger, when I was in, uh,
in college. And so he wants to come here and try something, right. So, you know,
the joker comes walking in and he's like, we'll take a table for two.
And immediately.
Immediately.
Clown Hunter's parents are like, Oh, prep and heat, Neil con Hunter,
like bowel goes to reach for a knife.
Now it's kind of one of these funny things because his dad steps in and says,
no, we don't escalate things, right. This is the joker we're talking about. Now.
This is the kind of fear that the joker has on the city of Gotham.
Not because of the fact that he's so incredibly violent.
That is part of the fear factor.
But because of the fact that he's so unpredictable,
you don't know if he's going to just kind of leave, like the joke,
we're just leave here and then go back and do his thing.
Or if the joker would massacre everybody in this place, right.
There's no way of knowing what the Joker's going to do because the joker schemes
don't make sense to anybody but himself. And so, because of that,
you end up having Bao. Who's basically told to kind of back off.
And then of course, joker and Harley Quinn are eating their meal and,
and that kind of a thing. And so Hartley's like, you know what?
We should get out of here. We should go find your,
we should go fend for these things, you know, that kind of stuff.
And the joke was like, that sounds good, right? Like go grab the car and,
and take the kids. But we're, we're wholly Quinn ends up leaving.
The joker still stays behind.
And this is a very daunting situation because now it's one of these things where
it's almost kind of like, okay, now it's just the two of us, you know? And,
and it's, it's, it's a little creepy, right?
Because this is usually where the joker ends up just kind of being insane.
And so ultimately he's told by the father of bow look the meals in the house,
man. Right. Like we really, we're really glad that you enjoyed it and, uh,
and make sure you get home safely. And, and the joke was like, okay, like,
you know, I really need to give you guys a big tip.
So here's a tip that I'm getting,
you don't breathe and like sprays and down with the,
with the joker talks enough. I'm going to be honest with you guys.
I kind of laughed when I was originally, when I was initially reading this,
I was like, okay, I know it's not funny, but it's, it's kind of,
it was kind of funny a little bit. And I was like, man, this is,
this is messed up. But ultimately of course it ends up exposing bow and his,
and his bows mother and father to the toxin. And that's how they're killed. Now.
This is why he associates Harley Quinn with that because Harley Quinn was part
of the duo of the joker, right.
She was part of the one-two punch that were Harley Quinn went, the joker went,
right. It's just kind of the nature of these things. And so because of that,
you know, Harley Quinn is every bit as, as complicit in the joker in this,
because Holly Quinn knew what the joker was going to do. Right. Well,
she knew that there was a high likelihood that he would kill them if the Joker's
insanity, uh, would lead him to do something bonkers. Right?
So she's just as guilty as the joker is, right?
Because she just kind of enabled it and allowed it to happen. Now,
when their bodies are being carried out,
this is when commissioner Gordon kind of steps up and says,
there's somebody who wants to talk to you.
And that's when Val comes face to face with Batman for the very first hunt.
And as the two of them are talking, there's a lot of anger inside Ballard.
He just lost his parents. There's a lot of anger, a lot of,
a lot of emotion and a lot of desire for vengeance.
And he asked Batman to make a promise, right?
Batman them a batarang and bowel says, make a promise, promise me,
you're going to do something about this right now, as we know with Batman,
he never really does anything about the joker, right?
So this was really a promise that Batman had no intention of keeping. And so,
because of that,
it basically leads to us kind of jumping back to this moment right now,
where you have Leslie talking directly with Bao himself.
And it's one of these things where it's, it's,
it's a really interesting conversation here because he kind of asked her,
you know, like, why did you, why are you helping me out here? Right.
I can be some kind of creepy weirdo killer. She's like,
I know that's what you are. Right. I know you're the clown Hunter.
I've heard of the clown, Hunter of the narrows. You know,
I know that you're one going around and killing everybody who work hound mask
during the joker war who committed all these heinous acts.
I know you're the person who's doing that.
The question I have is why did you come to me? And the funny thing is, again,
he's having a bit of an existential crisis that he found Harley Quinn,
that he got ahold of Harley Quinn.
He had the opportunity to kill Harley Quinn and he didn't.
And so now he doesn't know what he supposed to do, right?
If it's sole purpose for the last, you know,
however long was to basically track down and kill clowns everywhere he found
them. And then, then he let one go.
Now he's made an exception to the rule and because he lived his life,
but you know, being defined by this rule or at least lived a, you know,
a portion of his life being defined by this rule,
when you make an exception to the rule you live by then of what value is the
rule that you follow. And that's the, that's the, the,
the situation that he's in here,
that's what he's trying to figure out because now he's in that situation where
it comes to the line drawing, right?
That's the problem with making a substance to the rules is where do you draw the
line? Suddenly it shifts and changes all the time.
And that's not necessarily a bad thing,
depending on what rule we're talking about.
It's reasonable to have a hard and fast line on like killing people,
but like running a yellow light. No, Catherine,
I'm gonna pull you over for that. Right. Running a red light. Yeah. But like,
or going like 10 miles over the speed limit on the interstate, right.
There's kind of a hard and fast rules, right? Officially the speed limit,
75 artificially, it's like 85 or 90 possibly. If there's not really a cop that,
you know, not, not really hopping around you sometimes even a hundred or 110,
115, you know,
if you're hanging out with Benny and driving his Dodge challenger,
which is really well know, it depends on the situation, right.
It depends on what's going on, you know, depends on the rules.
But then the less, you know, it's,
it's one of these things where we're in his mind,
he almost kind of defines his existence in terms of video game logic right now,
before all the gamers start coming out earlier,
people are playing video games are violent. That's not what,
that's not what they're saying here. Right. And you know, better than that, the,
the point that he's making here is that in video games,
there is a direct reward system for what you do, right.
As video games are predicated on some kind of a point based system.
Maybe not so far as a direct point based system,
but like a point based system than the less right. XP,
leveling up different things like that. And so, because of that,
you commit an act you're rewarded for that act right now,
your reward may be something that you don't like, you you're,
you may be rewarded with a punishment, but you're rewarded nonetheless. Right?
And so, because of the fact that because of that,
he's kind of lived under the purview of his parents, right?
Do what I tell you to do, and you will get a positive reward. Uh, do you know,
do what I told you not to do, and you'll get a bad reward. You take that,
you combine it with the reward based system of video games.
And all he's really known his whole life is that if you do good things,
good things happen to you. If you do bad things, bad things to you.
And the reality is the world doesn't work that way,
that good things happen to bad people,
that bad things happen to good people and everywhere in between, right?
A person who has done nothing, but act like a Dick to people,
his entire life wins the lottery and a person who's been the nicest guy in the
world just always ends up coming up last, right?
Sometimes that's just the way that it works, right?
Not everybody gets their just desserts and walking around the world with the
philosophy of everything. Good happens to good people.
Everything bad happens to bad people is a recipe for disaster.
And this situation,
something terrible happened about his parents and they never did anything bad.
It flew in the face of everything he knew and what he desires is for sanity to
return to the world because his world has completely gone.
Topsy turvy it's turned upside down.
Now this became evident in the fact that as you know,
in the aftermath of meeting with Batman,
that he constantly recollected this promise that Batman made to him.
I promise you, I will, I will stop this. I promise you,
I will do something about the joker,
but every single time he turned on the TV or he saw the news or whatever it was.
And there was another escape by joker, from Arkham, asylum and joker,
going on another killing spree and killing more people.
And that then putting joker back in Arkham asylum,
and then joker escaping again, you know, like while he was, it was,
it was one of these things where it was constantly a case of Batman,
just never really doing anything to stop the joker.
Then he started to lose faith,
but he started to started to lose belief in the fact that joker would actually
do the right thing. And so it was one of these really,
really cool discussions that, that kind of takes place between Leslie and bow,
where he brings up this, this statement. He says,
there are things out there in the world that need to be done in life.
And that's what I don't get.
There's so much out there that's so obviously needs to get done,
but nobody's doing anything. If I don't do this, who's going to stop them.
All the people who took off their mask and went back to their lives.
And the response of Leslie is why do they need to be stopped?
Maybe they had a change of heart.
Notice the two completely differing opinions here. Leslie is a,
is of an opinion. Everybody should be forgiven for the things that they've done.
Maybe they changed their mind. Maybe they realize that they made a mistake.
Maybe they were somebody who was in a rough situation.
And it was their only real outlet, whatever it is,
it is an entire philosophy based on excusing people of their actions. But the,
but the, the stance of bow is no, we don't excuse them for what they did.
They did a terrible thing. They need to pay the price for what they've done.
That any possibility of receiving redemption went out the window when they
committed such heinous acts.
And this wasn't a situation of people who were going through and just like
robbing veins or anything like that.
And his mind when he goes through and he specifically targets these clowns.
It's because of the things that they did, that he kind of tells Leslie.
And he tells Leslie that the breaking straw for him was during the joker war
himself, that when he was going through, when he was,
when he was in his place and the whole thing started to pop off and all these
criminal sort of dawning clown mask and rallying themselves under the ideology
of the joker that they were doing. Things like burning people alive,
they were beating, beating people to death, right? They were, were satisfying.
Every despicable desire they had in their, in their minds and their bodies.
And in the, at that point in time, the way the bow saw it,
they were broken and they were beyond any real hope for redemption that any
chance they had of, of being able to say, Hey, look, you know, I'm,
I'm sorry for my actions that I want to repent. That's gone. Right? That's,
that's basically gone. Right. You know, it's,
it's one of these things is what does the Geneva conventions,
the Nuremberg trials saying?
I was just following orders is not good enough anymore.
And that's what makes clown Hunter so interesting because clown Hunter is kind
of the answer to the question.
What happens when a person doesn't believe the lies of Batman anymore?
When Batman says, I promise I'll do something about the joker, right?
What happens when somebody wakes up and says, every time Batman says this,
nothing ever gets done go that man,
can't be trusted to keep his promise in dealing with the joker. Right?
What happens when somebody gets to that point,
to the point that you get it's count Hunter,
because what ends up happening is there's a woman by the name of Mrs. NuGen,
who was set on fire by, by one of these guys in clown mask. And in that moment,
he snaps, right?
He has this recollection back to a statement that his mom had made to him.
Your father needs help. I need help. Don't lose yourself South in a fake world.
We need you here in the real world doing real things.
And that's when he kind of starts to realize the fake world is the world.
We're Batman will save us. The fake ones.
World is the world where we have to rely on Batman to make gossip a better
place, because the reality is if Batman was going to make Gotham a better place,
he would have, but he hasn't,
and therefore Batman cannot be believed or trusted.
And so it's one of these things where he basically says fine.
If Batman is going to be a half measure, then I will be a full measure.
And that's when he basically ends up taking the battery and he puts it into the
bat. He basically makes it a heat, literally uses the bottom of a,
of a broom and just like attaches, you know, all the little straws to his hat.
He paints it and he goes forward as count. Hunter grabs,
Neo takes the baseball bat. He's the crap out of one of the,
one of the clowns and then sets them on fire. And it's just kind of like,
you know, this is, this is the end, right?
We're a whole bunch of other clowns come after him.
He and turn kills all of them as well. And notice something.
He did something here that Batman has never been able to do,
do at the entirety of Gotham city count.
Hunter made these guys afraid to come to his neighborhood.
People are not afraid of committing crimes in Gotham because they're not afraid
of Batman. We know that because people commit crimes in Gotham, but in terms of,
of what's going on in, in crime alley, or at least in the narrows account,
Hunter, all these guys afraid to come to his neighborhood. They never came back.
Once.
Once he went on that warpath and killed every count he found they wouldn't come
back. And the reason why is because unlike Batman,
where all the most they have to be worried about is handed over to the justice
system, which is probably ill-equipped to handle them.
And then they're thrown in jail and like they escape or something like that.
With, with clown Hunter,
they have to worry about living that he introduced a level of consequence that
they simply just weren't willing to accept. And that's the nature of things.
That's the huge thing. That's the big difference here.
That was somebody like Leslie Thompkins.
She's avidly against the idea of using violence, right?
She says violence never solves anything. That's not true.
Violence solves lots of things, right? Violence is not always the answer,
but it is a answer. And it's a very effective answer.
Problem with violence is it makes people uncomfortable and it disrupts the
status quo. It kind of flies in the face of the comfortable life they live.
And it asks them to make sacrifices that they're just not willing to make.
Right? So people want things to change.
They just don't want to have to do anything that actually requires change. But,
but clown Hunter stepped in and said, no things need to change.
If people aren't willing to do what needs to be done to at least make my
neighborhood safer, then the hell with it, I'll do it on my own. And that's,
that's exactly how he became the character that he became. Right.
That's one of the interesting things here is because violence, again,
it introduces a kind of, it does create more violence. That's true.
But sometimes that's just the price you pay.
And ultimately you kind of have to end up becoming that kind of a person that
you have to become a kind of person where you look at a circumstance and say,
okay,
I'm facing off against a situation where the people involved just cannot be
fixed. They cannot be redeemed. There's no way to save them.
They're just too far gone.
And no matter what I do or what I try or how hard I work,
there's no way to bring them back.
And so the only way to make the world better is to get rid of them.
It's the only way. And it's not one of these,
these lines of logic that you use as a one-off, right?
Like that guy robbed a bank, kill him. That's not what you do. Right.
It's one of these things where it's like, okay, why is this guy robbing a bank?
Is this guy robbing a bank? Because he's in a really, really bad situation.
If he is, and how do we find a way to resolve that situation? Like,
is he down on his luck? Is he out of a job?
Is there something I can do to help him get back on his feet, to get a job?
There's all kinds of situations out there where you can use non-violence as a
means to improve people's lives.
But the ability to use non-violence to approve a person to improve a person's
life stops.
Once they demonstrate in corrigibility the inability and the refusal to stop
doing what they're doing and to keep becoming,
to literally keep becoming more violent.
The issue that you run into when you use that,
as you kind of create your standard in terms of,
at what point does somebody come for you? Right?
So if Khan Hunter is one of these guys where he's like,
I'm going to kill every single count out there,
every single clown that was there during the joker war, I'm going to kill them.
And then once, once they're all dead, then what do I do? Well at that point,
then it's like, okay, like you've served your mission.
And that's why if you're going to use violence as a means to achieve an end,
you have to have a clearly defined plan for why you're using that violence and
what your end goal is. And it cannot be an end goal where you can't,
you can't be like Batman. And just say,
I want to make sure nobody experiences the pain that I experienced when I was a
little kid. Okay. That's way too.
Open-ended what cloud Hunter has done here has actually been to create a kind of
defined purpose for what he's doing, right?
Like all these people who dress up as clowns and attacks in the narrows and bent
to their most baseline desires.
These are people that I'm going to kill because it's not as though, you know,
the whole event of the joker war turned them into something. They were not.
The truth is they were always that person. They were always that kind of person.
They were just looking for a reason to give them an excuse, to be,
to allow that version of themselves out. And so at that point,
all you're doing is just sparing the world,
the existence of what is already a terrible human being.
And the terrible nature of that human being is not arbitrarily defined by count.
Hunter is defined by the auctions of that human being. And so, again, it's,
it's one of these things where it makes clear and rational sense.
And that's why I say like hound Hunter is a full measure because he has a
clearly defined idea on who he's going to kill and why he's going to do it,
what the motive is and why they deserve to die.
And they're the reason why is because terrible people who did terrible things
and showed a callous disregard for everybody. Else's Hewitt for everybody,
else's life for the life of innocent people. And that,
that again is a big difference, right?
That's a huge difference going after an innocent person versus a guilty person.
And that's why like the world needs more clown hunters. That's me.
A crime will never go away 100%, but it can go away by a lot. Right? I mean,
it can go away by quite a bit, right?
Because dead men can not be repeat offenders. But the,
the funny thing about this is that there's this kind of discussion where count
hunters shows the Sonic kind of resolved this kind of initiative, right?
This ability to basically say like, you know,
I have the wherewithal and the capability to make Gotham a better place to
basically finish the job that Batman never finishes.
And what's the response he's given to you by Leslie Tonkin's come to my anger
management course, right? Like, yes, you have this incredible passion.
You have the ability to make Gotham better. And yes,
there are some people out there who just genuinely need to die,
but we don't want you doing that. Right.
Like come to my anger management course.
And it's kind of crazy because he even goes, as far as to ask her,
would you let the joker live? And she's like, yes, I would let the joker live.
I would, because deep down there there's still humanity.
There's something down there that can be saved, but he can't,
but the joker cannot be saved. There's no making him better.
There's no getting him to a place where he wakes up one day and says, my God,
what have I been doing all this time, man, I've just been killing people now.
I'm sure, glad Batman threw me into Arkham.
If he hadn't done it for the 100th time, I never would have learned my lesson.
Right. It doesn't, it's never going to happen. That's never going to happen.
So again, I champion the ideology of count Hunter and I champion the character.
It kinda sucks that she's asked him to join an anger management course. Right?
Like you have the ability to change Gotham city.
So we're going to try to stop you from doing that. You know, it's, it's,
it's kind of wild, but it is an amazing origin. I'll go. As far as to say that,
I think the origin of clown Hunter is probably one of the best origins I've
written a long, long time. It's absolutely amazing. But with that being said,
guys, we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to come and explain to make sure you guys have the sub
button to become part of the Rob Ford. If you guys enjoyed this video,
make sure you drop a light and that we'll catch you all later.
Please.